.
* Düstere Musik *
Ist gut, ja, ja.
Sergio, wie findest du es?
Sitze ich im Halbdunklen,
im Bild auch?
Ist das so halbkriminell oder was?
Allein über die Hovag
gibt es im Bundesarchiv über 13,5 m,
Aber hallo?
Hovag, die heutige Ems-Chemie.
Recherchen zeigen,
dass sie nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
Nazi-Chemiker engagierte.
Ja, das haben Sie mir geschickt. Ja.
Die Schlüsselfigur ist Johann Giesen.
Was war das für ein Mensch?
Sie kannten ihn persönlich.
Johann Giesen
kannte ich mehr als persönlich.
Wir hatten
ein sehr gutes Verhältnis.
Er war eine gestandene Persönlich-
keit - als Manager und als Chemiker.
Ça marche.
- Merci.
Das ist schwierig zu verstehen.
Eine beunruhigende Geschichte
Ich war der
wissenschaftliche Berater der UEK,
der Bergier-Kommission.
Es geht um Vorgänge
rund um den Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ich war im Team Industrie,
im Fokus die chemische
und pharmazeutische Industrie
und wir konnten alle Akten einsehen.
Es ist nicht zu gespenstig oder so?
Nein, nein.
- Ah, ja.
Dokumente belegen: Ein prominenter
sozialdemokratischer Politiker
stellte den Kontakt zwischen
Nazi-Chemikern und der Hovag her.
Sein Name: Robert Grimm.
Was meinen Sie,
als Vertreterin der SP?
Selbstverständlich wundert mich das,
aber er hat sich ja sicher
auch etwas davon versprochen.
Also ich muss sagen: Das weiss ich
alles nur aus der Erinnerung.
Ich war nicht dabei.
Ich war erst Ende der 60er-Jahre
dabei, da war der Krieg vorbei.
Und alles was ich jetzt sage,
weiss ich aus der Erzählung
und im Nachhinein.
* Düstere, pochende Musik *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
"Erfolg als Auftrag": Mit diesem Buch
feiert sich die Ems-Chemie.
Christoph Blocher und seine Tochter
Magdalena Martullo erzählen darin,
wie sie das Unternehmen
auf Erfolgskurs trimmten.
* Unterkühlte Musik *
Die Ems-Chemie: der grösste private
Arbeitgeber im Kanton Graubünden.
Ein Erfolgsunternehmen
mit Milliardenumsatz.
Ems feiert ihr 75-jähriges Bestehen
im Jahr 2011 mit Buch,
Ausstellung und Jubiläumsfilm.
(Originalton) Wir nehmen Sie mit
auf eine Zeitreise durch 75 Jahre
Unternehmensgeschichte von Ems.
Kommen Sie mit uns
auf einen Rundgang
durch die Jubiläumsausstellung ...
Willkommen, bitte sehr.
Die Ausstellung ist eröffnet.
Die Geschichte von Ems, geprägt von
drei Unternehmerpersönlichkeiten:
Unternehmensgründer Werner Oswald,
Christoph Blocher,
Magdalena Martullo.
Ein dunkles Kapitel aus der Zeit
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
fehlt jedoch in
der offiziellen Jubiläumsgeschichte.
Obwohl Historiker
bereits vor Jahren enthüllten,
dass Firmengründer Werner Oswald
umstrittene Personen engagierte.
Dr. Oswald wusste natürlich,
dass er mit den Entwicklern in Ems
ohne die deutsche Spitzenchemie
nicht weiterkommt.
Er musste bei dieser Spitzenchemie
anklopfen.
Im Buch fehlen Hintergründe
über die Hauptperson,
über Johann Giesen.
Johann Giesen war seit 1952
Forschungsleiter bei der Hovag,
also der späteren Ems Chemie.
Er blieb bis ca. 1970
im Verwaltungsrat.
Giesen spielte eine grosse Rolle.
Ein Mann mit dunkler Vergangenheit.
Wie genau er zu Dr. Giesen kam,
könnte ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Dr. Giesen hatte natürlich
ein entsprechendes Renommée.
Im Buch ist Giesen
nur mit einem knappen Satz erwähnt.
Kein Wort über seine Schlüsselrolle,
seine Vergangenheit.
Er war die zentrale Figur
für die Umrüstung der Hovag,
von einem kriegswirtschaftlichen
Triebstoffbetrieb
in die Kunststoffproduktion.
Das ist der Ausgangspunkt
des heutigen Wohlstand von Ems.
Ohne das Know-how,
das Giesen mitbrachte,
und v.a. ohne die Fachleute,
die wussten, wie man das umsetzt,
wäre das Werk Ems akut
von der Schliessung bedroht gewesen.
43 Jahre lang
leitete Werner Oswald die Ems-Chemie.
Dann starb er überraschend,
Christoph Blocher übernahm.
Man kann sich leichter machen, wenn
man den Kugelschreiber rausnimmt.
Das Ding ist jetzt halt ...
Weshalb steht nichts über
die Nazi-Chemiker im Jubiläumsbuch?
Ems hat also nie
etwas falsch dargestellt.
Wir haben dem nicht
das gleiche Gewicht beigemessen.
Und wenn Sie so
eine Firmengeschichte anschauen,
sind das alles Dinge,
die man später analysiert und sagt:
"Das ist auch noch komisch,
das waren Halunken."
Aber deswegen ...
Wir sind uns das gewöhnt
in der Industrie.
Wir arbeiten auch mit
Leuten zusammen, die Sünder sind.
Wie ist das genau abgelaufen?
Wie hat Werner Oswald die umstritten-
en Nazi-Chemiker angestellt?
* Düstere Musik *
Der pensionierte Ems-Chemiker
Marcel Capaul erinnert sich.
Sein Vater, ein Bündner Politiker,
sass jahrelang im Ems-Verwaltungsrat.
Ja, da sind wir im  ...
... ziemlich unordentlichen
Bastelraum von Herrn Capaul.
Das ist
übrigens die nette Aufnahme von mir.
Frau Martullo wollte von mir wissen,
wie es früher zu- und herging.
Ich durfte beim 75-Jahr-Jubiläum
eine der Festansprachen halten.
Das Bild entstand im Anschluss:
die hochzufriedene Frau Martullo
und meine Wenigkeit,
damals war mein körperlicher Umfang
noch etwas grösser.
Ausgangspunkt der
verborgenen Geschichte der Ems-Chemie
ist der Agraringenieur Werner Oswald.
Herr Oswald war sein Leben lang
eine totale Lokomotive.
Er hatte sieben Tage in der Woche
für nichts anderes Zeit.
An mir hat er den Narren gefressen.
Schon als Junge war ich für ihn
Marcel - das blieb ich auch.
In diesem Sinne war ich bei Ems
weitgehend ein etwas
aussergewöhnlicher Chemiker.
Ich habe Werner Oswald
relativ spät kennengelernt.
In den 60er-Jahren.
Er war ein sehr willensstarker Mann.
Er war beseelt von seiner Botschaft.
Er hatte bereits
mit 32 Jahren das Bedürfnis,
er wolle dem Bergkanton Graubünden
etwas Zusätzliches
zum Auskommen,
zum Wirtschaftsgedeihen bringen.
Er beauftragte sogar den bekannten
Schweizer Regisseur Kurt Früh,
einen Film darüber zu drehen:
(Originalton) Schon vor dem Krieg
hatten wir es schwer.
Es ging noch,
wenn man Arbeit im Wald hatte,
aber wie oft musste man
zu Hause bleiben,
weil man nicht gebraucht wurde?
Und jeden Tag das Brot aufzutreiben
für die Kinder, jeden Tag.
Manchmal fragte man sich nur noch:
"Wie mache ich es?"
(Capaul) In den 30er-Jahren hat in
Graubünden, besonders in den Tälern,
eine unsägliche Einfachheit,
Kargheit und Armut geherrscht.
Und wenn ein junger Rebell,
32-jährig, aus Zürich
bei der Regierung anklopft und sagt,
er habe eine Idee,
wie man aus Holz Treibstoff macht,
war das für die Bündner Regierung
und die damalige wirtschaftliche
Situation ein Wink des Himmels.
Darum hat er in den 30er-Jahren
schon vorhandene Patente
weiterentwickelt,
wie man aus Holz
einen Benzinersatz machen kann.
Methanol.
Und von diesem Gedanken
war er beseelt.
(Sprechchor) Heil Führer! Heil, heil!
(Originalton)
Deutschland marschiert.
* Gespenstische Musik *
* Knarren, Rattern, Zischen *
Und 1940 hat man gemerkt: Halt,
die Schweiz kann mit der Luftwaffe,
der Armee und auch zivilmässig
nicht existieren -
man muss von irgendwoher
Treibstoff bekommen.
Man geht davon aus, dass im Krieg
ungefähr 10 % der importierten Ware
im Vergleich zu vorher
importiert werden konnte.
Dann kam Werner Oswald und sagte:
"Ich habe ein Projekt,
wie wir synthetischen Treibstoff aus
einheimischem Holz machen können."
Doch dafür benötigt Werner Oswald
Geld, viel Geld.
Im Bundesarchiv in Bern
liegen die Unterlagen des
Eidgenössischen Finanzdepartements.
Darin der Finanzierungsantrag
an den Bundesrat,
ausgearbeitet unter Leitung
von SP-Nationalrat Robert Grimm.
Der Bundesrat bewilligt den Kredit.
Er war ganz der Meinung,
wie Werner Oswald,
dass die Schweiz diese Betriebs-
stoffproduktion machen sollte,
also aus Holz einen Benzinersatz.
Da hat er gefunden,
das müsse man jetzt machen.
Er hat auch
beim Bundesrat beantragt,
dass man bei Ems
eine solche Produktionsanlage baut
und der Bund die Investition zahlt.
Robert Grimm,
im Zweiten Weltkrieg verantwortlich
für die Treibstoffversorgung
der Schweiz.
Damals einer
der mächtigsten Sozialdemokraten.
Er war einer der wichtigsten Führer
der Schweizer Arbeiterbewegung
im 20. Jh.
Er schrieb Bücher und Schriften
mit grossem Widerhall.
Er kannte die marxistische Literatur
und die sozialistische Doktrin
sehr gut, weil er sich
auf internationalem Parkett bewegte.
Er besass viele Kontakte
ins Ausland,
v.a. aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg,
wo er eine wichtige Rolle
in der internationalen
Arbeiterbewegung einnahm,
um gegen den Krieg zu kämpfen.
Im Zweiten Weltkrieg
gehört Robert Grimm zu jenen,
die sich energisch
gegen den Nationalsozialismus wehren.
Gemeinsam mit Werner Oswald
will er die Schweizer Armee
mit Ersatztreibstoff versorgen, damit
sie die Schweiz verteidigen kann.
Herr Grimm wollte als Marxist
im Ersten Weltkrieg
in der Schweiz eine Revolution
nach russischem Muster durchführen.
Er, der an der Spitze stand beim
Generalstreik, hat sich dann dort -
entweder durch Überzeugung oder
Opportunismus - so hingestellt,
dass er sogar als
Spitzenbundesbeamter gewählt wurde.
Kein Wort im Ems-Jubiläumsbuch
über Grimm.
Doch seine Rolle
für Oswalds Unternehmen war zentral:
Und innert knapp eineinhalb Jahren
hat man 1941
eine Riesenfabrik aufgestellt,
für eine x-fach grössere Produktion
von Treibstoff,
im Sinne von Ethylalkohol.
Mitten im Krieg auf der grünen Wiese
ein Chemiewerk aus dem Boden
zu stampfen, war ein Höllenritt,
muss man sagen.
Wenn ich diese Quellen lese,
bewundere ich manchmal,
wie viel Energie und
Entschlossenheit er gebraucht hat,
um das überhaupt durchzuziehen.
Es hat nicht alles geklappt:
Die Rohstoffe haben gefehlt,
die Maschinen sind zu spät gekommen
und haben nicht funktioniert.
Die Arbeiter mussten wieder
ins Militär, es gab keinen Strom.
Der erste Winter, in dem gebaut
werden sollte, war so hart,
dass die Bauarbeiten
eingestellt werden mussten.
Und das war
eine sehr steinige Angelegenheit.
Das konnte nur einer machen der,
ich sag es mal so,
mit dem Kopf durch die Wand ist.
Er hat sich enorm eingesetzt
und hat einen unglaublich
persönlichen Einsatz gezeigt.
Er hatte drei Herzinfarkte.
Er war Tag und Nacht unterwegs.
Keine Pause, kein Privatleben.
Nichts.
Der hat
bis tief in die Nacht gearbeitet.
In der Regel hat man gesagt,
er gehe erst kurz schlafen,
wenn die Vögel draussen pfeifen.
Und dann steht er aber
gleich wieder auf.
Ich war ihm zu Diensten - das kann
man so sagen - Tag und halbe Nacht.
(Originalton) Im grössten Werk des
industriearmen Kantons Graubünden,
im Holzverzuckerungswerk von Ems,
finden mehr als 1'000
Arbeiter/-innen ihren Verdienst.
(Originalton) Grundlage
war das Holz der Graubündner Wälder,
der ganzen Schweiz.
(Originalton) Das Abfallholz
wird in Hackrotoren
zu Schnitzeln zerkleinert.
Die Schnitzel
werden mit Sägemehl vermischt.
* Fanfarenartige Klänge *
* Trommelschläge *
(Originalton)
Nach komplizierten Arbeitsgängen
sind aus 100 kg Holz
mehr als 20 l Alkohol geworden.
Gemischt mit Methanol entsteht
der Benzinersatz für die Armee.
Doch die hergestellte Menge
genügt nicht,
die Schweizer Armee braucht mehr.
Das war klar.
Es reichte nie
für die Versorgung der Schweiz,
man hätte dazukaufen müssen.
Die Grenzen waren schon zu,
aber die Schweiz versuchte immer,
Güter aus den besetzten Gebieten
zu erhalten.
Und dort waren natürlich Nazis.
Man musste mit denen verhandeln,
die dort das Sagen hatten.
Darum sagte Grimm, er müsse
mit denen dort draussen reden,
um die notwendigen Güter
zu erhalten.
Robert Grimms rechte Hand
ist Ernst Imfeld.
Der Zürcher Rechtsanwalt
besitzt exzellente Kontakte
zu höchsten Kreisen
des Dritten Reichs.
Imfeld und Grimm
verhandeln während des Weltkriegs
mit SS-Hauptsturmführer
Ernst-Rudolf Fischer
und mit Friedrich Kadgien.
Kadgien ist die rechte Hand
von Reichswirtschaftsminister
Hermann Göring.
Die Verhandlungen sind erfolgreich,
bald rollen wieder Tankwagen
gefüllt mit Benzin in die Schweiz.
Über Ernst Imfeld pflegt
der Antifaschist Robert Grimm
plötzlich Kontakte
zu Nazi-Deutschland.
Es ist ja noch
nicht vollständig aufgearbeitet,
aber er hat sicher
eine Rolle gespielt.
Er hatte selbstverständlich Kontakt
mit Funktionären des Dritten Reichs.
Er war zuständig für die Versorgung
mit Treibstoff, auch für die Armee.
Er war eingeschlossen
von Achsenmächten.
Im Frühling oder Sommer 1940
wusste man nicht,
wie der Krieg ausgehen würde,
wie lange er noch geht.
Er musste diese Versorgung
sicherstellen.
Er war stark national fokussiert
und wollte einfach,
dass die Leute in der Schweiz
überleben können,
möglichst viel ihrer Freiheit
bewahren können,
ohne grossen Blick
über die Landesgrenze.
Grimms und Imfelds SS-Kontakte
bleiben nach Kriegsende wichtig,
v.a. für die Hovag,
die heutige Ems-Chemie.
Insbesondere deshalb,
weil SS-Hauptsturmführer Fischer
damals Direktor
beim grössten deutschen
Chemieunternehmen I.G. Farben ist.
* Rattern, Knattern *
* Marschmusik *
The German war
is therefore at an end.
In Graubünden stehen nach Kriegsende
über 1'000 Arbeitsplätze
auf dem Spiel.
Nach dem Krieg
war das sog. Emser-Wasser
sofort nicht mehr so aktuell.
Werner Oswalds
synthetische Treibstoffproduktion
ist mit Millionen von Bundesgeldern
finanziert.
Doch die Abnahmeverträge
sind befristet.
Als der Krieg zu Ende war,
wusste Oswald aufgrund
seines Vertrags mit dem Bund,
dass er ein Zeitfenster
von zehn Jahren hatte.
In dieser Zeit
musste er die Firma umbauen.
Er musste weg vom Treibstoff,
weil der viel zu teuer war.
Er musste sich überlegen, was er
in den zehn Jahren machen kann,
um unabhängig
von der Treibstoffproduktion
und den Subventionen zu werden
Er musste etwas anderes produzieren.
* Energische Bläsertöne *
Nylon
lautet der neue Trend aus den USA.
* Jazzige Trompetenklänge *
(Originalton) New York has a run
on the nylon stocking.
* Bedächtige Klaviermusik *
Die deutsche Kriegswirtschaft hat ein
ähnliches Produkt entwickelt: Perlon.
Für Werner Oswald und seine Hovag
ist Perlon  d i e  Lösung.
Dr. Oswald wusste natürlich,
dass er mit den Entwicklern bei Ems
ohne die deutsche Spitzenchemie
nicht weiterkommt.
Er musste
bei der Spitzenchemie anklopfen.
Die hatten nach dem Krieg
natürlich Chemiker.
Und da sind ganze Reihen
von ostdeutschen Chemikern gekommen,
die natürlich alle eine national-
sozialistische Vergangenheit hatten.
Im Ems-Jubiläumsbuch steht kein Wort
über die Nazi-Chemiker.
Wie kamen sie nach Ems?
Robert Grimms und Ernst Imfelds
Beziehungen ins Dritte Reich
sind entscheidend.
Kurz vor Kriegsende
flüchten die SS-Mitglieder
Ernst-Rudolf Fischer und
Friedrich Kadgien in die Schweiz.
Robert Grimm und Ernst Imfeld
halten ihre schützende Hand über sie.
Als die Alliierten
die beiden Nazis suchen,
schreibt
die Schweizer Bundesanwaltschaft:
"Die Aufenthaltsbewilligung
von Kadgien und Fischer
wurde auch von Nationalrat
Robert Grimm wärmstens empfohlen."
Auch Historiker
der Bergier-Kommission
schreiben von engen Kontakten
zwischen Grimm und Fischer.
Fischer vermittelt via Grimm
Johann Giesen,
Perlon-Spezialist bei I.G. Farben.
* Geheimnisvolle Musik *
Im Schweizer Bundesarchiv
findet sich der Beweis:
ein noch nie publiziertes Telegramm:
Grimm lädt Giesen
zu einer Besprechung nach Bern.
Der sozialdemokratische Nationalrat
spielt also eine zentrale Rolle.
Er vermittelt einen Nazi
an die Hovag.
Was sagt die SP dazu?
Es gibt Forschung, die zeigt, dass
Grimm selber blinde Flecken hatte.
Das wirft natürlich dann auch
seinen Schatten auf die Partei.
Das ist mir klar. Die Frage ist,
ob wir dafür verantwortlich sind,
was früher gemacht wurde
oder können wir nicht einfach dazu
beitragen, dass man das aufarbeitet?
Johann Giesen wird jetzt
Forschungsleiter bei Ems.
Dr. Johann Giesen war der Träger
der deutschen Spitzenchemie.
Und als Träger der deutschen
Spitzenchemie kam er zu Ems
und in seinem Gefolge mindestens
20 Chemiker und Spezialisten.
Dank ihnen kann Werner Oswald
seine Firma retten.
Oswald war extrem schlau
und sehr gut,
wenn es um PR
und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit ging.
Er hat sich wohl überlegt:
"Okay, das ist ein gewisses Risiko
für meine Firma und auch für mich."
Er hat sich auch überlegt,
wie er davon profitieren konnte.
Die Geschichte zeigt uns,
dass er das Gefühl hatte,
dass er mehr davon profitieren,
als verlieren konnte.
Und darum hat er sich
auch mit denen eingelassen.
* Geheimnisvolle Musik *
Wissen Sie, in der Industrie haben
wir nicht immer die Möglichkeiten -
das ist auch heute so - zu fragen,
welche Gesinnung derjenige
auf der anderen Seite hat.
Wir arbeiten doch auch
mit Kommunisten zusammen,
obwohl wir keine Kommunisten sind.
Politisch zählt nicht.
Wenn einer der Chef einer Fabrik ist
oder auch Chemiker dort ist,
dann müssen wir reden mit ihm.
* Pompöse Bläserklänge *
(Originalton)
Ein Produkt ist geboren
ebenso verarbeitungsfähig wie Wolle,
aber widerstandsfähiger
und dauerhafter.
Grilon ist
die einzige vollsynthetische Faser,
die vollständig
in der Schweiz hergestellt wird.
So wurde aus dem Treibstoffwerk
von 1941 im Rahmen dieser Umstellung
das bedeutendste
Bündner Industrieunternehmen.
Ein Betrieb,
der in Notzeit entstanden war,
begann sich selbstständig zu machen.
Er schuf neue Produkte, eine schwer-
ringende Bevölkerung ernähren
und einen
nicht krisenfesten Kanton stärken.
Die gesamte Umstellung
wäre ohne die deutschen Chemiker,
die Oswald zu Ems geholt hat,
gar nie möglich gewesen.
Graubünden und die ganze Schweiz
hätte diese Spezialisten
in keiner Weise hinbekommen.
Man weiss auch,
dass diese Chemiker z.T. ganze
Anlagebaupläne mitgebracht haben,
die sie bei ihren vorherigen
Arbeitgebern geklaut haben.
(Originalton) In diesem Augenblick
wird ein Schaufenster in Zürich
mit zauberhaften Grilongeweben
geschmückt.
Und Fräulein Müller wäscht
zum 50. Mal die Grilonstrümpfe,
die immer noch fein wie Seide
und wie neu sind.
Oswald hat ja der Öffentlichkeit
immer gesagt,
er produziere jetzt Grilon,
also Nylon aus GR-aubünden.
Er hat das als schweizerische
Eigenleistung verkauft,
was eine totale Augenwischerei war.
Wer war dieser Johann Giesen?
Giesen ist aus der alten deutschen
Firmengeschichte zu verstehen.
Als Mann im weissen Kittel.
Und war er nicht nur
der erfinderische Chemiker,
sondern damals war der Chemiker
auch der grosse Manager.
Dr. Johann Giesen war schon rein
äusserlich das reine Gegenteil
des hohen, dünnen, hageren
und spartanisch lebenden Oswald.
Er war jovial,
kam ähnlich einem Churchill daher.
Er rauchte dauernd eine Zigarre
und reicherte sein Bier
gern mit Steinhäger an.
Er genoss also nebst
seiner Tüchtigkeit als Fachmann
auch das Leben.
Er war für uns Schweizer
kein sympathischer Mensch.
Das muss ich also sagen.
Er war gross und mächtig.
Er hat immer geprotzt.
Er hatte am Morgen eine Flasche
Whiskey auf dem Schreibtisch
und war sehr herrisch.
Er hat während dem Krieg
eine ganz wichtige Rolle gespielt
als oberster Chef
der Methanol-Synthese.
Und Methanol haben die Deutschen
auch gebraucht als Treibstoff.
Aber Methanol ist natürlich
ein weitgespannter Grundstoff
der Chemie.
Schlussendlich für Munition
und für alles Mögliche.
Da war Dr. Giesen
natürlich eine Koryphäe.
Giesen hat also
für die deutsche Wehrmacht
eine wichtige Rolle gespielt?
Wohl oder übel, zweifelsfrei,
wie manch anderer.
Die deutsche Wehrmacht
braucht synthetischen Treibstoff,
denn Deutschland
besitzt keine Ölreserven.
Methanol als Treibstoffersatz
ist zentral für den Krieg,
Johann Giesen ein wichtiger Mann.
Giesen arbeitet
für den Chemiegiganten I.G. Farben.
Das Unternehmen
versorgt die deutsche Wehrmacht
mit vielen
kriegswichtigen Produkten.
Johann Giesen leitet
das Industriewerk Auschwitz-Monowitz.
Er war von Anfang an
federführend beim Aufbau
der Methanol-Produktion
im I.G.-Farbenwerk in Auschwitz.
Und 1944,
als ein anderer Direktor starb,
hat er die Gesamtleitung der
Treibstoffproduktion in Auschwitz
verantwortet.
Das gesamte Werk Auschwitz
der I.G. Farben
war ein strategisches Projekt.
Auf der obersten Ebene wurde auch
mit Hitler direkt verhandelt.
* Brummende,
furchteinflössende Klänge *
Man weiss, dass für den Bau des
I.G.-Farbenwerks in Auschwitz ...
Das wurde systematisch
mit Häftlingen
aus dem Konzentrationslager gemacht.
Zuerst aus dem Hauptlager
von Auschwitz und später,
weil das zu weit weg war
und die Häftlinge
7-8 km zu Fuss laufen mussten,
hat man ein eigenes KZ gemacht,
direkt neben dem Werkgelände,
respektive noch im Einflussbereich
von I.G. Farben.
Und man weiss,
dass dort schätzungsweise
25'000 KZ-Häftlinge
im Arbeitseinsatz gestorben sind.
Die durchschnittliche Überlebenszeit
für Arbeiter auf der Baustelle
war rund drei Monate.
Also man weiss,
die Vernichtung war das Ziel.
Man hat versucht,
die Leute zur Arbeit anzutreiben
unter aller Gewaltanwendung,
solange man sie benutzen konnte.
Man kann sich etwa vorstellen,
wie die Arbeitsbedingungen waren.
Nur ganz wenige haben
dieses Arbeitslager überlebt.
Es war ja direkt neben Auschwitz,
da hat man entschieden,
wer noch arbeitet und
wer direkt in die Vernichtung kommt.
* Beklemmende Klaviermusik *
Die Bedingungen
im Konzentrationslager von Auschwitz
sind furchtbar.
Die Beschreibung von Primo Levi,
der im Spätfrühling 1944
dorthin kommt,
klingt grauenvoll.
DerChemiker Primo Levi
überlebt Auschwitz-Monowitz.
Er verfasst das berühmte Buch
"Se questo è un uomo" -
"Ist das ein Mensch?".
Darin beschreibt
er die Arbeitsbedingungen.
Ich denke nicht,
dass ich geschrieben hätte,
wenn ich nicht diesen extremen Druck
verspürt hätte.
Was ich in Auschwitz sah und erlitt,
löste in mir das grosse Bedürfnis
zu schreiben aus.
Unmittelbar nach Kriegsende
veröffentlicht Levi einen Brief,
in dem er seine Erfahrungen
ausführlich schildert.
Insbesondere erinnert er sich,
dass dieser Bereich von
Dr. Johann Giesen geleitet wurde.
Er war
für die Produktion verantwortlich,
und tatsächlich erzielten sie
bereits bemerkenswerte Ergebnisse
in Bezug auf Methanol.
Wussten Sie, dass das erwähnte
Methanolwerk in Auschwitz war
und mit Zwangsarbeitern
betrieben worden war?
Sprach man darüber?
- Nie.
Das ist mir völlig neu.
Das habe ich im Buch nachgelesen.
Es ist natürlich so,
wenn man Chemiker war,
musste man dort in meinen Augen
irgendwie mitmachen.
Man hatte keine Wahl.
Und wenn das nebenbei von Zwangs-
arbeitern hergestellt wurde ...
Es waren überall Abermillionen
von Zwangsarbeitern.
Die, die während dem Krieg
solche Fabriken aufgebaut,
beraten oder produziert haben,
waren Nazis.
Eine führende Stelle hat sicher
keiner erhalten, der kein Nazi war.
Wann haben Sie zum ersten Mal
über Johann Giesens
dunkle Vergangenheit erfahren?
Das war sehr viel später.
Ich habe Giesen
aus den Augen verloren.
Als ich nur halbtags da war,
habe ich ihn zufällig gesehen,
aber ich hatte nichts mehr
mit ihm zu tun.
Und nachher, ähm ...
... sind ähm ...
Ja, ich weiss nicht ...
Es sind gewisse Artikel erschienen,
es habe hier Nazis gehabt.
Number 6 will come to order.
Nürnberger Prozesse 1947:
Die Amerikaner
klagen die I.G.-Farben-Führung an.
Einer der Angeklagten
im I.G.-Farbenprozess,
den die Alliierten gegen Nazi-
Kriegsverbrecher geführt haben,
war Heinrich Bütefisch.
Er war SS-Angehöriger
und gehörte zum Freundeskreis
von Heinrich Himmler.
Heinrich Bütefisch
war der Chef von Leuna,
dem riesigen Triebstoffwerk und er
war auch der Chef von Johann Giesen.
Heinrich Bütefisch.
- Bütefisch.
* Brummende Musik *
Und Johann Giesen
hat während dem Prozess in Nürnberg
zu seinen Gunsten ausgesagt
und hat versucht,
ihn mit diversen Aussagen
und Behauptungen zu entlasten.
"Ich, Dr. Johann Giesen,
versichere eidesstattlich:
"Die auf der Baustelle beschäftigten
Konzentrationslager-Häftlinge
sind stets korrekt und anständig
behandelt worden."
"Von Vergasungen habe ich
erst nach dem Krieg etwas gehört."
Giesen erklärte
am Nürnberger Prozess,
er sei sich der Ausbeutung
der Zwangsarbeiter
des Konzentrationslagers Auschwitz
nicht bewusst gewesen.
Er habe auch nichts
von den Gaskammern gewusst.
Doch Levi sagt, es sei unmöglich,
dass Giesen von nichts wusste.
Wenn man es liest,
wird einem ganz anders.
Es war eine komplette Verharmlosung
dessen,
was auf der Baustelle in Auschwitz
passiert ist.
Johann Giesen kannte diese sehr gut,
weil er häufig dort war.
* Dumpfe,
aufwühlende Streicherklänge *
Das kam mit der Zeit hervor.
Das wusste man ja
nicht von Anfang an.
Aber es stimmt, die machten
natürlich auch solche Sachen.
Das war in der Nähe
vom Konzentrationslager.
Es hiess, man hätte auch
Zwangsarbeiter von dort ... also ...
Das schliessen wir nicht aus.
Aber wie gesagt,
es mussten alle vor Gericht,
die für die Zwangsarbeit
verantwortlich waren.
Das war der Nürnberger Prozess.
Aber Giesen ist
nicht in Betracht gezogen worden.
Man hat gesagt, er war von aussen
her der Erbauer und er behauptete,
dass er nicht wusste,
dass es Zwangsarbeiter waren.
The Tribunal will proceed
with the arraignment.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Heinrich Bütefisch
wurde zu sechs Jahren Haft
wegen Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit verurteilt
und im Zusammenhang mit der
Ausbeutung von Sklavenarbeit
von KZ-Häftlingen
und ausländischen Zwangsarbeitern.
Er war einer jener Konzernleitungs-
mitglieder der I.G. Farben,
die eine Haftstrafe bekommen haben.
Andere sind freigesprochen worden.
Über den Prozess
berichtet auch die Schweizer Presse.
In dieser Zeit
ist Johann Giesen in der Schweiz.
Im Herbst '47
wurde zwischen Giesen und Hovag
über genaue Verträge verhandelt.
Das war genau dann, als der I.G.-
Farben-Prozess in Nürnberg lief.
Das ist ganz klar,
dass das Gesprächsthema
Nummer 1 war.
Alle wussten,
dass die vor Gericht stehen.
Sogar die Belegschaft
im Emser-Werk wusste das.
Den genauen Zeitpunkt
wusste man nicht.
Man wusste, dass Giesen
eine Vorladung hatte in Nürnberg.
Ich gehe davon aus: Werner Oswald,
der auch im Nachrichtendienst
und sehr gut informiert war, wusste
das auf jeden Fall, ganz klar.
Ich nehme an, dass er auch
Referenzen von den Leuten einholte,
politischer und technischer Natur.
Sie sagten, was sie gemacht hatten.
Wenn jemand über dessen
Vergangenheit Bescheid wusste,
hätte er nicht zulassen dürfen,
dass dieser sich
so ein Leben aufbauen kann,
ein völlig normales,
respektiertes Leben.
Nach all dem, was dieser getan hat,
hätte das wirklich
nicht möglich sein dürfen.
Wenn ich mich in diese Zeit
zurückversetze, muss man sagen,
dass Giesen im I.G.-Farben-Prozess
nicht angeklagt war .
Er hat dort ausgesagt,
aber als Zeuge,
während 23 andere
dort vor Gericht standen.
Die Alliierten haben Giesen
ja dann zum Direktor gemacht
von einem der I.G.-Farbenwerke
in Süddeutschland, in Uerdingen.
Er hatte ja eigentlich
fast schon
den
Alliierten-Unbedenklichkeitsstempel.
Ich kann nachvollziehen, dass jemand
damals gedacht haben könnte:
"Wenn die Alliierten ihn einstellen,
wird das ja wohl in Ordnung sein,
dann kann ich das auch machen."
Tatsächlich war Johann Giesen
für kurze Zeit
von den Alliierten angestellt,
das Dokument findet sich
in den Akten von Robert Grimm.
Was wusste er über Giesens Rolle
im Methanolwerk Auschwitz-Monowitz?
Einen Hinweis liefert
ein vertraulicher Brief an Grimm -
verfasst von Ernst Imfeld:
"Mein Lieber,
deutsche Fachleute,
mit denen ich mich über Giesen
unterhalten konnte, erzählten,
dass Giesen selbstverständlich
eine Kapazität sei
mit Bezug auf Industrie-Organisator
in seinen Gebieten, also Methanol,
dann auch Perlon."
Ich glaube,
es ist weniger darum gegangen,
dass man nichts wusste,
welche Rolle die Leute spielten.
Man wusste,
sie hatten eine führende Rolle
im I.G. Farbenkonzern gespielt.
Man wollte weiterhin
mit ihnen Geschäfte führen,
weil sie wichtig waren
für die Schweiz.
Das ist schwierig zu verstehen.
Eine beunruhigende Geschichte.
Ich persönlich bin der Ansicht,
dass sich Robert Grimm aufgrund
seiner politischen Überzeugungen,
seiner Vergangenheit
und seines Engagements
hätte distanzieren müssen.
Ich kann das Verhalten Grimms
ehrlich gesagt nicht nachvollziehen.
Und die Sozialdemokratische Partei?
Was sagt sie dazu?
Wollen Sie, dass die SP Schweiz eine
Medienmitteilung veröffentlicht,
die heisst: "Robert Grimm
als Nazi-Sympathisant entlarvt"?
Finden Sie nicht, es ist Aufgabe
der Forschung, das aufzuarbeiten?
Die Frage ist, und das ist
nicht abschliessend belegt,
was Grimm genau wusste.
Giesen wurde ja sogar
von den Alliierten entlastet.
Das soll keine Entschuldigung sein,
aber die Frage ist tatsächlich,
was der Wissensstand war - von Grimm
und auch der breiten Öffentlichkeit.
Das ist jene Zeit, wo man sich sagt:
"Gut, jetzt haben wir andere Sorgen,
andere Prioritäten."
"Wichtig ist jetzt
die Erholung der Wirtschaft,
die sowjetische Bedrohung."
"Deshalb können die Leute,
die für die I.G. Farben
oder mit dem Nazi-System gearbeitet
haben, auch für uns arbeiten,
wenn es für die Schweizer Wirtschaft
nützlich ist."
Dr. Oswald hat selber
viel erzählt aus dieser Zeit.
Von der Schweiz her, vom Westen her.
Er hat aber auch gesagt,
man solle nicht alle Deutschen
wegen dem verdammen,
was sie gemacht haben.
Man hat dann über das eine
oder andere hinweggeschaut.
Das ist heute auch so. Schauen Sie
sich die modernen Kriege an.
Wenn sie beendet sind,
dann gibt es immer viele Schuldige.
Weil sie in dem Land,
in dem es weitergeht, dabei sind,
redet man mit ihnen,
ohne ihre Auffassung zu teilen.
* Aufwühlende Musik *
Nach Kriegsende, im Mai 1945,
gab es einen internationalen Run
auf die deutschen Wissenschaftler
und Techniker.
Die Alliierten - Wernher von Braun
ist ein gutes Beispiel -
hatten die Operation Paperclip,
wo auch politisch vorbelastete
Wissenschaftler angeworben wurden.
Die Russen
haben das natürlich auch gemacht.
Wernher von Braun, NSDAP-Mitglied,
verantwortlich für das V-Raketen-
Programm von Nazi-Deutschland.
Die Raketen bauten Zwangsarbeiter
in unterirdischen Bunkern.
Nach dem Krieg wechseln
von Braun und sein Team in die USA.
Präsident Kennedy empfängt ihn.
Die haben Wernher von Braun
mit 300 Leuten zu sich geholt
und im Schnellverfahren
entnazifiziert.
Also ...
Die Russen haben dann
die zweite Garde geholt.
Das war ein Riesenrun
nach diesen Leuten.
Die Amerikaner haben schon geschaut,
dass sie die richtigen Leute
bekommen.
Wernher von Braun
wird in Amerika ein Volksheld.
Berühmt wird der Wissenschaftler
mit Nazi-Vergangenheit
insbesondere als Leiter
des Apollo-Mondlandeprogramms.
Nach seiner Haftentlassung arbeitet
auch der verurteilte Kriegs-
verbrecher Heinrich Bütefisch
wieder für die Chemieindustrie -
u.a. als Berater von Werner Oswald.
Im Archiv der Ems-Chemie findet die
Bergier-Kommission Korrespondenzen
und Besprechungsnotizen:
Wir haben dann festgestellt,
dass er Briefkontakt hatte
und ein Beratungsmandat der Hovag
in den 50er-Jahren.
Man hat mit diesen Leuten
gearbeitet, obwohl klar war,
dass das verurteilte
Kriegsverbrecher waren.
Man ging davon aus, als er '51
aus der Haft entlassen wurde,
dass man jetzt wieder
mit denen arbeiten kann.
Von Bütefisch
habe ich gar nie etwas gewusst.
Der war im Jahr 1964 fertig und über
ihn hat man auch nicht gesprochen.
Den Namen habe ich ab und an
in der Geschichtsliteratur gesehen.
Ich würde Oswald so einschätzen,
dass er sich sehr wohl bewusst war,
dass das eine Gefahr sein kann
für den Ruf des Unternehmens,
wenn er sich mit Nazis einlässt,
wie jetzt z.B. einem Bütefisch.
Der wurde in Nürnberg
zu sechs Jahren Haft verurteilt,
wegen Versklavung
von Zwangsarbeitern.
Da wusste man ja,
mit wem man es zu tun hat.
Man muss sehen:
Das waren alles ganz tüchtige Leute.
Das waren nicht
irgendwelche Dummköpfe,
die diese Sachen aufgebaut haben.
Das waren gescheite Leute,
die aber charakterlich versagten.
Bütefisch erhält im Jahr 1964 sogar
das deutsche Bundesverdienstkreuz.
Doch ein Opfer
macht seine Vergangenheit publik,
der deutsche Bundespräsident
reagiert.
Man hat ihm das Verdienstkreuz
wieder weggenommen.
Das war, so glaube ich,
auch der Punkt, warum Oswald sagte,
er arbeite nicht mehr
mit ihm zusammen,
obwohl er Direktor
von diesem Werk war.
Sie gehen davon aus,
dass Werner Oswald
die Zusammenarbeit mit Heinrich
Bütefisch beendet hat, weil ...
Ich kann es nicht beweisen,
weil ich nicht dabei war.
Aber so, wie er über sie Ende
der 60er-Jahre sprach und warnte:
"Passt auf mit den Kontakten.
Es gibt noch Leute, die ..."
Er dachte, auch noch zu jener Zeit,
hätte es solche gegeben.
"Passt auf!"
Ich habe gemerkt, dass es etwas ist,
dass er innerlich sehr ablehnte.
Ob Werner Oswald die Zusammenarbeit
deshalb beendete, bleibt also offen.
Die Ems-Chemielehnt es ab,
die Oswald-Korrespondenz
im Firmenarchiv offenzulegen.
Begründung:
Die Bergier-Kommission habe:
" ... alle vorhandenen Archivalien
bereits gründlich aufgearbeitet."
"Eine erneute Sichtung
für Ihr Projekt
würde deshalb
keine neuen Erkenntnisse bringen."
Robert Grimm starb 1958.
Viele Fragen bleiben offen.
Z.B. weshalb
der prominente Sozialdemokrat
nach dem Krieg bei der Fremdenpolizei
für das SS-Mitglied
Ernst-Rudolf Fischer gebürgt hat.
Es ist für mich
schwierig zu beurteilen.
Er hatte sicher engen Kontakt mit
diesen Leuten während des Krieges.
Er musste
die Versorgung sicherstellen,
das soll aber
keine Entschuldigung sein.
Man kann höchstes sagen,
dass das ein Zeitgeist war,
dem sich auch Robert Grimm nicht
aktiv entzogen hat nach 1945,
vergessen, was war.
Und man wollte sich
nicht vorstellen,
inwiefern diese Leute
in der Vernichtungsindustrie
involviert waren.
Robert Grimm
hat einfach weggeschaut?
Ja. Robert Grimm
und auch ganz viele andere Leute.
Ich würde da v.a. auch
die Bundesanwaltschaft ankreiden,
weil man nicht weiter geschaut hat.
Selbst wenn wichtige Behörden-
mitglieder oder Politiker sagen,
man müsse nicht weiterschauen.
Dann wäre es doch auch die Aufgabe
einer Behörde wie dieser,
weiter zu recherchieren.
Es ist nicht recherchiert worden.
Das Bild ist natürlich
etwas weniger glorreich als das,
was man nach dem Krieg
gezeichnet hat:
Die Schweiz als uneinnehmbarer Igel,
bereit zum Widerstand, abgeschottet.
Die Realität war viel komplexer.
Es war eine Mischung aus Kalkül,
Opportunismus und Taktieren -
entsprechend den Notwendigkeiten.
Ähnlich wie die Ems-Chemie,
die in ihrem Jubiläumsbuch
das Kapitel über die Nazi-Chemiker
von damals weggelassen hat.
Obwohl sie es waren,
die dem Unternehmen
nach dem Krieg eine
erfolgreiche Zukunft garantierten.
Wir arbeiten mit allen Menschen
auf der Welt
und wir müssen auch mit solchen ...
Wir haben auch Betrüger,
von denen wir später feststellen,
dass wir mit ihnen zusammenge-
arbeitet haben. Manchmal unbemerkt.
Das ist halt so.
Das ist die Welt,
so ist halt das Leben.
Aber wir hatten nie eine Gesinnung
in diese Richtung, das ist wichtig.
Wir haben diese Chemiker
aus Deutschland nicht angestellt,
weil wir wie Werner Oswald
nazifreundlich wären.
Das ist dummes Zeug.
Werner Oswald
starb im Februar 1979,
43 Jahre nachdem er die Hovag,
respektive die Ems-Chemie
gegründet hatte.
Was ich erstaunlich finde:
Es gab nie eine öffentliche Debatte.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck,
durch die ganze Rhetorik
von Oswald ...
"Hovag - ist eine
schweizerische Pionierleistung."
"Wir helfen dem armen, struktur-
schwachen Kanton Graubünden."
"Wir helfen den armen Bauern."
Noch besser: Wir helfen den
Bergbauern, das klingt noch besser.
Dieseganze Rhetorik
war wie eine Art Nebelwand,
hinter die schlussendlich
keiner mehr richtig geschaut hat.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Dr. Giesen wurde schon sehr alt.
Man hat ihn eines Tages
nicht mehr gesehen ist.
Dr. Giesen ist einfach ...
He was fading away,
wie der Amerikaner sagt,
wie eine Kerze erloschen, für Ems.
Von seinem Tod habe die Ems-Chemie
erst im Nachhinein erfahren,
sagt Capaul.
Irgendwie hat er Platz gemacht,
für den kommenden Wechsel mit dem
daherstürmenden Christoph Blocher.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Danke.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020